this is how you make crispy eggplant  see I'm not the biggest fan of eggplant  but I can eat a lot of this all right  first thing we're going to do is we're  going to peel the eggplant okay for this  recipe we're using a Chinese eggplant  because a regular eggplant's too chunky  you want a skinny one so it can fan out  all right that has been peeled we're  just gonna cut it lengthwise like this  and we're gonna turn it and do it all  over again okay so if you did it right  your eggplant should be able to dance  like this next step is to make the  batter two eggs flour chicken stock  powder for flavor pinch of salt some  black pepper then you're gonna coat the  eggplant completely with this Panko  bread crumbs okay now that looks  beautiful  we're going to transfer to a wired rack  we're just gonna let that cool down now  can you cut them into matchsticks and  fry them like a regular person would  absolutely but that's not fun and I'm  just trying to provide options  okay  okay